hello believe nation I'm Evan Carmichael
my one word is believe and I believe
that entrepreneurs are going to solve
all of the major problems of the world
so to help you on your journey today
we're going to learn from Chinese actor
Jet Li and my take on his top ten rules
of success rule number two is my
personal favorite and I'd love to know
which one you guys like the best and as
always guys if you're watching if you
hear something that really resonates
with you please leave it down in the
comments below put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired and when
you write it down it's much more likely
to stick for yourself as well
enjoy
[Music]
Rene what RCC people you meet in Adobe
form entry to the community ecology gave
of mission was our hero fancied oh well
you're the Hydra boo go back so disarmed
a super hero watch
now SOT so sudo su ho varadananda Bob
shunpo dawn paparazzo dock window
Yemanja tsuyoshi-san he artificial
situation comedy central virginia
minions are o'connell vision yamazawa a
volatile apparent solution solution dead
to settle a nod to the jolly cookie
she's just a chief I mean what do the
two models we hand out your top 3 town
with the jewelry pinnacle that she's
acquired a fool sir Stanley de Janiero
missive are you and occupation new yella
he's illegible Shuford fight it out oh
my
don't you already talking twice the
magnetism to show we do I do now I'll
always in my life believe the biggest
enemy is ourselves when in the final we
learning special professional Marable
everybody get a lot of injured in the
past you need a fire wisdom overcome
every day you know you need work
continue and you know to show your
strength strength and to your best and
as I think it real mean the fearless
today from JB's head is to your past
every day that sort of thing and lighted
without a cop it cannot control let me
go her an encounter doesn't matter
do your best everything every day in
every day training worth everything to
school eNOS if I do something I do my
best
I don't know the future but if I really
want to do I start
try to my best I'm not Bruce Lee I'd
never can be booth you know he is a
different age Tiffin
different philosophy may be different a
lot of things are different you have you
every human being is a unique you have
your special ability you need to make
that become unique if you follow someone
they are always you're the follower
you're another creator
I always show myself forgot the past
what I do what I did on the past and the
new guy today - every day is new things
happen I need to learn English I needed
learn things learn American style this
movie success but a next movie maybe not
so you need to learn again I'm the new
actor here every day so this is my
philosophy I need to learn it it's
normal guy a plate of different
characters also I need a learner I with
the Chinese have been famous ascendance
how when you how to translate when you
become older older you still need to
learn alert it's all the time today's
lesson is what about you doll oh that's
alright
oh yeah if you're older older older but
you need still need a study a study
study yes because that's the very good
sign has sent me to preach to the world
whether you can do better than the other
so that means you need to fire yourself
physically and mentally
you always need to prove for yourself
you can do something different
if you can show your talent and the
approve of course you'll have a very
good future
I really hope all the Asians without the
ten major in the world they needed
create their own even you can learn
something special from different people
that you need to make yourself prove
yourself you're the one in China harder
than the space because in States the
people just like it then they either
have a job or they have a family they
need to go to school and a training in
flowers maybe three times a week but in
China a lot of students training a hours
they still longer still cleaning a hours
day so that's why they there were so
hard I remember when we need to put in
my legs in the on the wall like that for
flowers flowers then the teacher is the
God we do know where is the teacher that
is way scared a teacher you know I mean
honey time is maybe she come back so we
still keep the lake on the wall for
flowers of the powers as the whole
training nothing just one leg put on a
wall but
after that we're watching like it fit
like a dog couldn't walk I think it
whatever your cell says would not it
just become happier - do you really want
to do
now for the just name your money you
need to do something you really want to
do not feeling is the most important for
me every day I the moment I'm still
think about how to help helping protect
you know work so myself I wanted to
promote how to help people is more
important just like if I do make a March
or movie it's maybe not so many people
know martial art what is martial art
what is going through in China
so I'm not independent the open school
to teaching but I'm a promote majora
just like a blind now I promote new way
to do NGO and work philosophy in the
21st century everybody can do when we
talk about it helping people mainly me
away from do it
the philosophy behind the foundation is
that a small donation made regularly by
many people and make a huge difference
to the lives of millions in need or
instead puts it if one person donates $1
every one month adds up to one big happy
family the human dear lady nerds like a
bigger gobo Faddis the main foundation
when family I'm a human being
even we are religion different system
different languages given the color
different by the we're human we need
helping each other not just Chinese
people helping Chinese we need up
everybody helping each other all right
run along long time long they always say
issue religious the truest he loved
parties you never go home drinking
smoking but every morning if you're qg
and ijk always talk about his last movie
rush hour this work with super style who
gusta Chris doctor but I met Chris are
you see he really want to work with me
Jackie
Jeff always compared himself to Chris
Tucker you know Chris Tucker is very big
man you know Jake is really like a you
know collection cars watches you know
that's reason speakers he really
and she demands everybody call him on
the set hero hero dad hero there would
you like a patty hero would you like
some food massager hero oh okay
another things understand you cannot
look him in the eyes you fire ridiculous
and Jackie I always make it talks you
know everybody make everybody laugh but
you know everybody laugh if you don't
ask if are you know Jeff off safe is
here to prove with the very top the true
is is here very dry sticky out look II
need to shame no I work Emma saying he
always shows much change the show is
powerful man but star worried about is
here is they're looking here I always
give him check each and product points
here if we fuse use without here nothing
doctor how will channel not to leave
India really Dania direction
case Allahu Allah yada yada yada
chicken cacciatore rocoto home joke or
engage in Jana was a young - Jean
Valjean Jean humble little dalliance
ando ando conducive real when you are we
thinking the return and exchange among
ten million dollars so dividing
assessment come on Amanda they are very
great at what I am is a bundle - laughs
please being
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Amanda McBride
asked me to so there's someone you'd
like me to cover in the next top ten
video check out the link in the
description so you can go and cast your
vote I also want to give a quick shout
out to both Hawkins both thank you so
much for picking up a cup of my book
your one word and doing that interview
on your new youtube channel it was an
awesome time and I appreciate the
support today I'm joined by the
outstanding Evan Carmichael so if you've
been online you don't know who he is
you've probably lived under a rock for
the past infinite time so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
for the bigger picture you can no human
being half of 500,000 history right
everything to protect people a lot of
things happen whatever how harder we try
next 5,000 years you have a lot of
problems cannot be perfect perfect
perfect
it's not this planet love this earth
because we have a lot of cultures mother
religion lot of things
Lala these are a lot of problems today
we face this problem 200 years later
there is not a problem the most
important we want to share is 21st
century beliefs if every seventeen to
little bit not as earthquakes a lot of
things education you know a lot of
things we can change
I think believe is the most important
that's why does the Harvard professor
told me they I like your idea I want to
study your idea you know become the
class because everybody come to my
office ask how do you get money I need
the money
teach me how do get the money so
everybody talk about money money money
money right
but when foundation is the first one is
lot of money is the heart if you can
share the beliefs to the people's heart
people he come in in a more people
trying the family that's big very strong
foundation right right because think
about it in China nothing buddy in China
we have a community to people even we're
having 200 people
how does have a billion people problems
even impossible but if everybody join
this family we can do something I mean
it's about for you it sound like it's
about selling the belief believe in the
forever
yeah Pixability overall if you get which
is one everyone to do something funny
the impact will be huge that's why you
know in the photographer go with it a
lot of things is not a been present
because a charity famous law it's a lot
of NGOs helping us yeah
the unveils a lot of companies they
don't need a name they just support a
win foundation there's a whole
foundation moving together with all
those suits on we have a 500 volunteers
we're a confirm I don't know I don't
know if even do know their name their
work very hard hard about clearly very
just what maybe to just planning well
they're really a lot if they're really
doing something go to the may a lot of
places right right it's pretty things
you think I really want to say the
primary you're not JD is not even funded
if the finally power is very strong
right I remember two years ago when the
two silver offered means lay the bike
avail indeed 11 floor then I say oh I
made a twenty five movies in Hong Kong I
never played villains so I don't know my
audience what's their reaction when they
heard the news so it don't worry here is
a good guy he offered not always
rooming much time so when one by Guy
when good guy
you can work you have a special skill
you can make a money for the studio than
in the future right now may be better
than before I have a little bit chance
which can choose what kind of story I
really want to make it I hope in the
future I have more chance and choose
what kind of story I really want to make
what kind of story I don't want to let
make it hi gently my name is thuy and
I'm from Australia you say you are very
successful and that's obvious and you
know my Ling and very optimistic that
fabulous but I believe every successful
person has failures or experience
setbacks in their life and you share
with us what are some of your failures
in life and how you overcome this to
achieve success in your life thank you
shishah can you double come
Hunter's were filming the title just
wither jungle shoe box that had a pinata
gallery restoring GJ yva solution Hajime
also him hyo's obey and in someone
girdle lady she teach any misery here
for me super essential guna and only
when I'm in good jobs like this should
mean she's idea if I'm a long standoff
big abortion or so way the success or
just single shake a thing
sure much I talk to you [ __ ] make
Lawrence maven yelling 1k the thing he
don't worry yeah
so you at home I poker champion Google
survive what's care just what Mary
camcorder yeah ye war Mayo fufu what a
machine what Allah Bhagwan they will
shoot at that beam there is no some and
paper that y'all go change what you know
each is thought you may want come back
with the Dark Samus religious she does
not stop just stop breathing you may
mayor and Karen Shiva you TV show me to
your seller if they're so easy to mr.
Sharma no de Cuba may or it isn't that
even nobody guaranteed very what you
some theologians Anton were the later
chun-yin them food in soil religious
that were similar Josie eager until it
could nowadays a dream compiler I don't
call them giving them some people music
aah Chilean pooja of the penis of gender
genius young adult are similar I made a
similar utility changes our life when it
comes to setbacks and successes I think
they're just normal to me I would like
to look at with a peaceful mind it's
just like for your hand you have palm
and you have the back of your palm so
these are two things just being there if
you talk about the successful people you
can think about the Chinese emperors in
the past few hundred years are they
successful I don't even remember some of
the names of these Emperor's
so when it comes to success it really
depends on
the nation of the Dead and in different
times people define success differently
and for me is like success to me is like
every day I have to leave it live it
meaningfully I have to I I don't want to
do something bad and I have to when I
daya I I should be able to face my
ancestors my teachers my parents so I I
don't really know when I'll die so
that's that's reason why I have to make
use of every day when I'm leaving here
to do something I can't say I will wait
until I retire to do something for the
philanthropy no it's not that
and good things bad things they're just
normal they're just common things to me
like the stocks if they go up last year
it's normal to me this year last year
Goes Down Goes Down and this year goes
up it's all normal to me